bonjour madame vous avez donc maintenant
quitter l'hôpital necker où un cortège
s'est élancé et les manifestants ont le
corps lourd aujourd'hui mais exactement
ils ont choisi la saint-valentin non
seulement pour déclarer leur amour à
l'hôpital public mais également pour
continuer à se mobiliser il va toujours
le palais depuis plusieurs semaines déjà
malgré le plan d'urgence lancé par le
gouvernement ils demandent plus
d'effectifs et surtout une
revalorisation salariale vous pouvez les
voir juste derrière moi un cortège
composé de plusieurs incendies cac iliad
est beaucoup beaucoup de monde plusieurs
centaines de personnes sont dans ce
cortège profil est différent également
les aussi des enfants qui donnait
quelques pancartes en il y avait écrit
pédiatrie en détresse donc on a vu un
panel de personnes ici on a vu également
passé eric coquerel de la france
insoumise on a pu parler à ces gens je
vous propose d'ailleurs de les écouter
on est venus démonter ce qu'on dénonce
depuis des mois la la le manque de
moyens humains le manque de bras le
manque de lits le manque de
reconnaissance ne manque d'argent le
manque de salaires donc pour tout le
monde quoi parce que au final chacun est
concerné parce que le b clément 6 si on
a des soignants et qu'on est en mauvaise
santé
on pourra pas prodigué des soins de
qualité quoi le gouvernement reste sourd
donc c'est pour ça aujourd'hui on est là
dans la rue pour manifester encore une
fois notre mécontentement
on sait pas vraiment ce qu'il faut faire
pour que la ministre est de l'inde rompt
nous écoute
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on aille tous cas
c'est pour avoir un petit peu là une
vision sur nous et eux et que les gens
prennent enfin conscience coeur
l'hôpital est en train de s'effondrer
voilà c'est on sait plus trop quoi faire
aujourd'hui à part parce que maire de
man qui priorise le privé est qui et qui
laisse le public s'effondrer clairement
si c'est le manque de reconnaissance et
de respect de notre travail
les fermetures de ligne
les patients qui ne sont plus pris en
compte en tant que tel et l'arrêté des
salaires bas et des conditions de
travail aux qui se dégrade de plus en
plus déclarer sa flamme à l'hôpital
public et surtout leur préserver pour un
hôpital qui se dégrade de plus en plus
vous l'avez entendu c'était les
témoignages du membre hospitalier ici on
est actuellement boulevard montparnasse
et ce cortège qui s'élance dans les rues
de paris et bien il aura pour point
d'atterrissage l'hôpital la pitié
salpêtrière